REV. ADAM RICK: Almighty
Father, creator and sustainer
of us all, you have brought
us safely to this day.
Give us minds to
thank you for all
of your providential mercies.
Lord Jesus Christ, only son
of the Father and Savior
of the world, you have shed upon
us the light of your intoning
embrace.
Give us hearts to
love you in return.
Holy Spirit, advocate
and guide, you
have made us to be fit
vessels for your glory.
Give us wills to
walk in step with you
to bring forth your fruits.
Most glorious and
blessed Trinity,
ever one God, by the blood
of the eternal covenant
you have adopted us as children
into your divine family.
We ask now that you
so guide our minds,
so fill our imaginations,
so control our wills
that we may be wholly yours--
utterly dedicated to you.
And then use us, we pray,
as you will and always
to your glory and the
welfare of your people.
This we ask with boldness
on the merits of Jesus
Christ our Savior.
Amen.
Please turn and face
the flag with me.
ALL: I pledge allegiance
to the flag of the United
States of America, and to the
republic for which it stands,
one nation under God,
indivisible, with liberty
and justice for all.
[ORGAN PLAYING]
[CHOIR SINGING]
[ORGAN PLAYING, CHOIR SINGING]
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Good morning to
all and welcome to the fall
convocation.
A special thanks to our
organist, Dr. Derek Stauff,
to the Hillsdale
College Chamber Choir
under the direction of Professor
James Holleman and Debbi Wyse,
and to Reverend Adam Rick for
the invocation and benediction.
Distinguished members
of the platform party
today are Dr. Larry
Arnn, president.
Dr. Michael Ward, our speaker.
Dr. Mark Kalthoff,
dean of faculty.
Dr. Matthew Young, dean
of natural sciences.
Dr. Stephen Smith,
dean of humanities.
Dr. Paul Moreno, dean
of the social sciences.
Dr. RJ Pestritto, graduate dean.
And Reverend Adam
Rick, college chaplain.
Now for the scholarships.
Hope this the right one.
Nope, wrong one.
All right, the all-school
grade point average
for Spring 2019, 3.399.
This is the same every time.
The all women's average--
so remember, 3.399-- all
women's average, 3.486.
The all men's average, 3.317.
With a GPA of 3.520, the
sorority scholarship goes to Pi
Beta Phi.
Would a representative
please come forward.
[APPLAUSE]
With a GPA of 3.302, the
fraternity scholarship
goes to Alpha Tau Omega.
Would a representative
please come forward.
[APPLAUSE]
Larry P. Arnn is the 12th
president of Hillsdale College.
He received his BA from Arkansas
State University, graduated
with highest distinction.
He received his MA and
his PhD in government
from the Claremont
Graduate School.
He also studied
in England, first,
as a research student
in international history
at the London
School of Economics
and then in modern history
at Oxford University.
While in England he also
served as director for research
for the Sir Martin-- for
the late Sir Martin Gilbert,
the official biographer
of Winston Churchill.
He returned to the United
States to become editor
for Public Research,
Syndicated, and he
served as president of
the Claremont Institute,
an educational
research institution
based in Southern California.
While at Claremont, he
was the founding chairman
of the California Civil
Rights Initiative,
which was passed by
California voters in 1996,
and prohibited racial preference
in state hiring, contracting,
and admissions.
Dr. Arnn is on the
board of directors
at the Heritage Foundation,
the Henry Salvatore Center
for Claremont McKenna College,
the Intercollegiate Studies
Institute, and the
Claremont Institute.
He served on the US Army War
College Board of Visitors
for two years, for
which he earned
the Department of Army's
Outstanding Civilian Service
Medal.
In 2015, Dr. Arnn
received the Bradley Prize
from the Lynde Harry
Bradley Foundation.
He is a member of the American
Political Science Association,
the International Churchill
Society, the Mont Pelerin
Society, the Philadelphia
Society, and the Philanthropy
Roundtable.
Published widely in national
newspapers, magazines,
and periodicals on issues
of public policy, history,
and political theory, he is
the author of three books--
Liberty and Learning
The Evolution
of American Education, The
Founders' Key The Divine
and Natural Connection
Between the Declaration
and the Constitution and
What We Risk By Losing It,
and Churchill's Trial Winston
Churchill and The Salvation
of Free Government.
Dr. Arnn and his wife,
Penelope, have four children--
Katie, Henry, Alice, and Tony.
Please join me in
welcoming Dr. Larry Arnn
[APPLAUSE]
LARRY ARNN: Good morning.
Can you hear in the balcony?
Ah, it works now.
Welcome.
This building was built
with this service in mind.
We hope it works for it.
I see the Academy has
showed up in force,
and their behavior was
OK, I thought, coming in.
Good job.
Is Duncan Stroik here?
Supposed to be here.
I was looking for him.
Oh, he's up there.
What are you doing up there?
AUDIENCE: So I can hear better.
LARRY ARNN: So he
can hear, yeah.
There was a problem.
Duncan Stroik designed
this building,
and we should
thank him for that.
[APPLAUSE]
I see that several senior people
in the college administration
are sitting on the dangerous,
precarious front row there.
And if one of them falls off,
there'll be a job opening.
[LAUGHTER]
Are you curious who actually
built this building?
They sit right there.
Would you stand up, please?
[APPLAUSE]
This building is produced by
the love of millions of people.
And that includes those people--
I visited this building
many more times
than I had time to do
and many more times
than I've ever built
in another building
because it's wondrous
to watch it unfold.
And I know-- is
Larry Weigand here?
No, he couldn't come.
Tell him I said this.
I said it before.
Weigand Construction Company was
the general contractor on this,
and about halfway through
they told Mr. [INAUDIBLE]
that they were going to lose
about a million bucks on this.
I think it was more than that.
Why?
Because nobody's built
anything like this forever.
So it's hard to estimate what it
would cost, what it would take.
And then they told
us a great thing.
They told us not--
they weren't going
to tell these people that,
because they were trying
to build this building perfect.
And they didn't want
them to stop doing that.
So the names of
all of these people
are going to go
on a plaque that's
going to be put up in here
and preserved to thank them
for their service.
It's spectacular to watch.
Thank you for showing
me what you did.
[APPLAUSE]
We held this service
for something north
of 160 years in the
College Baptist Church
that's down the street.
It was built in a partnership
between the college
and the town--
started in the 1850s.
Over the years things changed.
The college never owned that
church, but it was-- it's home.
And over the years
things changed.
The college has a
glorious history,
but like all long histories,
it has its modulations.
And they altered
the structure so
that it would seat
fewer people, and they
had more space for other kinds
of activities in the back.
And the college grew.
And so we thought, we
have to do something.
About 20 years ago, we
made a plan for the campus.
And I was the one who said
we have to have a chapel.
I didn't know what I was saying.
I knew enough to know that
it would be difficult,
cost a lot of money,
not yield much revenue--
that kind of thing.
There's so many things
around here like that.
And I didn't know
where it should be.
And back then, it could not have
been where it sits right here.
I noticed that the
chapel places me
in a reverie when I come in
here because one forgets--
life is so busy.
One forgets the things
that have happened.
And here, this is a
reminder of things
that had to happen for
this chapel to be here.
And when we began, we didn't
know what those things were.
This back of the campus--
we had to remove an obstacle--
our largest classroom building.
And it has been described
by great architects as ugly.
And these guys over here,
they had their offices in it,
and they were so
happy to be in there.
And there was a large crowd
of faculty gathered when
we started tearing it down.
There was a great chomper,
and it-- it's a big old brick
building-- brick
inside and out, as was
the style here for a while.
And the chomper bit into it,
and there were loud cheers.
And then I ran up
to the foreman.
I said, wait, that's
the wrong building.
[LAUGHTER]
The student union is here
now, and this fits with that.
Duncan has made it so.
Eventually, something is
going to happen over there.
I don't know what and in God's
good time, but what's over
there is going to fit with this.
And the center of the
campus is an integrity now.
We're going to redo the back
of Central Hall, God giving us
the dough.
And it's going to look like
the front of Central Hall.
And it's going to match
with this back here.
And David Whalen
will have a quarrel
about the window
with Duncan Stroik
and whether it should
match the window
in the front of the Central
Hall or whether is should match
that window right up there.
So far the betting is
Duncan is going to win.
He won the last one.
And David sallied
forth many times.
So you see, this
is a development.
Development toward what?
The college has been trying
to become fully itself
since the beginning--
intensely in recent years.
Why?
Everywhere around
us, there's a crisis.
There's decay.
There's simmering conflict or
actual conflict everywhere,
and the conflict concerns
every fundamental thing.
What does family mean?
What does God mean?
Do people who love God--
are they committing some injury
against their neighbors--
which is a public
claim often made now?
And so in a time like
that, CS Lewis writes,
things come to a
point, and there's
not as much neutral ground
as there used to be.
And so we are
responding to that.
And we're all here today to
thank God that this happened.
Because we who were actually
in charge of making it happen,
we didn't know until the
last step what it would take.
Most plans are made
through principle and hope.
And there's an element of
practical judgment required,
but when you look at
a thing like this,
you see that that's
not such a big element.
So much has to happen that
you can't just make happen.
We should remember to
be grateful for that.
Your students are going to carry
the college into the future.
That's actually your job, to
learn what it has to teach.
Understand that you've
come to it in a time that's
very different
here than anywhere
else, because the things
that we were made to teach
are what we seek to teach.
And not many people learn that.
You are the point.
Think about this building.
Think about the
relationship it represents
between faith and learning,
between faith and freedom.
Think about that, and for
the rest of your life,
teach others about
it, because they
don't get the chance to learn.
I always make a hash of this,
so I'm going to do it again.
It's not the Emily
"Daw-tree" Award--
it's the Emily Daugherty Award.
Does anybody know
if that's right?
And the woman who
gave this anonymously
is a particular friend
of mine, and her name
is Susan [INAUDIBLE].
And I always say her name,
and I always mispronounce
the name of her mother.
It's crazy.
But we are grateful to her,
because she thought this up.
And it maybe is one of the--
it's not maybe.
It's one of the
best awards we give.
Why?
Because it's given in the fall
to a junior faculty member--
and in the spring
to a senior one--
for being an excellent teacher.
And that is the point
around here, isn't it?
And there's so many of
you sitting over there.
If you stay here long
enough, you're going win it.
Or else, somebody's
going to kill you.
We're going to sit you up there
on that front row up there.
This year's winner is a
fulfillment of a prediction
I made--
the prediction I made when we
hired a certain faculty member,
and I said, if we heard that
guy, the first thing that's
going to happen is the
classes are going to swell up
and we're going
to have hire more.
This is the more.
He's a fine young man.
He's a superb scholar.
He's an excellent
colleague to the people
in the German department.
Yaniga was the one we hired.
And I could just see--
the great Eberhard Geyer was
the chairman of that department
then, and it's just grown.
Stephan Naumann has
been here since 2013.
He got a BA in pre-seminary
studies in 2001.
Oh, I didn't know this.
You should all study with him.
He has a bachelor's degree
in tourism and travel,
as well as German.
Get that guy to
take you to Germany.
MA and PhD in German studies.
He spent time in Germany and
Poland, where he met his wife.
His German and
Polish are fluent.
He knows a little
Spanish, he says.
He learned-- see, that's
the way I put it--
he learned ancient Greek--
also biblical Hebrew and Latin--
while at pre-seminary.
I like to say that,
the past tense.
I learned Greek.
Do I remember any?
Not enough.
Stephen Naumann is a
blessing to the college,
and we are grateful to have him.
Please come forward
with Fred Yaniga.
[APPLAUSE]
Sorry.
Hey, guys, I forgot
about the money.
Naumann gets money and
the department gets money.
And I think that's
Blackstock's idea,
so that they wouldn't quarrel.
[APPLAUSE]
Was anybody else
particularly struck
by the grade point
averages this year?
Do you realize that the
academic standards of the girls
and the boys at Hillsdale
College are the same?
Did you realize that we
have as many applicants--
or now a few more lately--
from boys than from girls?
Nobody gets that.
And yet the boys, what are you--
because you're not dumb.
It's got to be bad character.
Straighten up.
I'm not going to comment
on whether the scholarship
winner among the fraternities
had a higher or lower grade
point average the
men's average--
which is, of course, notoriously
lower than the women's average.
So if we compared
those numbers, we
might think the Greek
boys ought to study more.
I'm just saying.
You're all doing
fine, and we probably
won't throw you out of here--
probably.
We don't pay Michael
Ward enough money for us
to call him our
own, but if somebody
will please work out a deal
with him, then we will.
I'm tired of hinting about it.
He is a remarkable man.
He's got long experience as
a chaplain and a professor
in both Oxford and Cambridge.
He's a fellow at
Houston Baptist.
And I don't know
what he does there,
but whatever that is,
he should do it here.
There are two distinctive
things about him.
One is I've called him before
the best student of CS Lewis,
and he is that.
I think that more
now than I did then.
His book Planet
Narnia is tremendous.
And what he did was just take
seriously what the book meant,
which is what professors
do, when they are any good.
And it's a revelation
to read it.
And it makes you
marvel at a thing
that you may already
have loved, because you
see that it is a work
of art on a higher level
than you realized.
That's what happened to me.
The second thing is he's
got this wicked wit.
He's been here twice before to
give important speeches-- once
commencement.
And in this
commencement speech, he
gave one of the finest
commencement speeches any of us
has ever heard.
But it began with
about five minutes
of making fun of the
name of the college.
Because it is a
weird name, isn't it?
You ever heard anything
else named Hillsdale?
There's only one
place I know of,
and it was directly copied
after us, down in Oklahoma.
And why?
Are you going to do it again?
I'm going to remind him.
He said, is it a dale
belonging to a hill?
It's kind of silly.
And then he redeemed himself
by associating the name
with an imaginary world
he made up as a kid called
Tor or something--
Tordale, right.
It's a synonym for Hillsdale.
By the way, that's
the kind of thing
Lewis and Tolkien did
when they were kids,
and when they were grown.
They made up the fantasy world
and they named stuff in them.
So this is another
third really weird guy.
We asked him to speak at the
groundbreaking of this chapel.
And that was just
right to do, because
of what he is, what he
represents in the world,
so much like what
we try to represent.
And now we've asked him to
speak at our first convocation--
also extremely appropriate--
Michael Ward.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL WARD: Good
morning, everybody.
Thank you for having me back.
Yes, I was at the groundbreaking
2 and 1/2 years ago,
and it's a huge privilege now
to see this building complete
and fully splendid.
I congratulate you,
President Arnn, and indeed,
everybody concerned--
builders, architects,
college in general--
in bringing this massive project
to a successful conclusion.
Last time I was here,
I seem to recall,
I attempted a little
spirited wordplay--
not about Hillsdale on
my most recent visit,
but on Dr. Arnn's academic
expertise in Churchill,
and on this church on a hill.
And here it is.
But of course, what we
find ourselves within today
is not strictly a church.
It is a chapel.
And so I want to
begin my remarks
by asking why this building
has been called Christ Chapel.
Well, there are several
answers to that question.
It's been called
Christ Chapel partly
to reflect the devout
Christian faith
of the principal benefactors,
Jack and Jo Babbitt.
It's partly Christ Chapel
because its architecture gives
homage to that church
in Philadelphia,
where America's Founding
Fathers worshipped
during the Continental Congress.
And I'll be coming back to
that church in Philly later on.
For now, I just want to
note that that church was
and is called Christ Church.
This is Christ Chapel.
So what is the distinguishing
feature of a chapel?
What is the etymology
of the word chapel?
And to answer those
questions, I invite
you to accompany me in
imagination back in time
to fourth century Europe.
It's the early fourth century,
and the emperor Constantine
is presiding over
the Roman Empire.
We find ourselves in a part
of Europe somewhat to the east
and somewhat to the
south, in what would today
be called Hungary.
We're in a province
called Pannonia,
and we enter the house of a
soldier, whose wife has just
given birth to a baby boy.
The mother and the
father give their son
the name Martin, from Martinus,
diminutive of Martius,
pertaining to Mars--
a highly appropriate name, not
only because the boy's father
is in the Roman army, but
because Martin himself
will soon grow up and enter
upon a military career himself.
He becomes an officer,
and is assigned to duty
in Gaul, modern-day France.
On garrison duty at
Amiens one winter's
day, as he rides through
the city gates on his horse,
Martin does something that is
so unexpected, so memorable, so
striking that it's been
recounted in literature
and represented
in art ever since.
On that cold day,
this young tribune,
dressed in the
regalia of his unit--
gleaming armor, ridged
helmet, large white cloak
lined with lamb's wool--
he sees a poor man
begging by the roadside--
a man whose clothes are
so ragged that he's hardly
covered at all.
The beggar is shaking
with the cold,
and Martin, on an impulse,
jumps from his horse,
commands two of his retinue
to dismount with him,
takes off his large white
cloak, orders his two men
to hold it out taut between
them, and then with one
quick stroke of his sword, he
slashes the garment in two.
He then hands one
half to the beggar,
pulls the remaining half around
his own shoulders, remounts,
and rides on his way.
That night, he dreams.
He dreams and sees Christ in
heaven saying to the angels,
Martin clothed me with his robe.
And after Martin's
death many years later--
he died in the year 397--
the part of the
cloak that he kept
was preserved in his
honor in an oratory
of the Abbey at Tours in the
middle of France, 150 miles
southwest of Paris.
And what does all this have
to do with the word "chapel"?
Let us consult the
dictionary, which tells us
that the word "chapel"
derives from the capela,
or cloak, of St. Martin,
preserved by the Frankish kings
as a sacred relic.
The term chapel,
the dictionary says,
was applied to the
sanctuary in which
this cloak was preserved under
the care of its capellani--
or chaplains-- and
thence, generally,
to a sanctuary containing
holy relics, and finally
to any building for
orisons or worship
not being a regular church.
Thus says the Oxford
English Dictionary,
and if Oxford says
so, it must be true.
So this soldier, this
caped crusader, Martin,
is now known to the world
as St. Martin of Tours--
T-O-U-R-S. The S is silent.
But if you are Churchillian,
you would say "tours."
Churchill scorned
those English travelers
who insisted on saying they'd
visited Marseilles, Lyons,
and Paris.
No, he said, you visited
"Mar-sails," "Lions,"
and "Pair-us."
Foreign names were made for
Englishmen, not Englishmen
for foreign names.
And I'm sure Churchill would
have called this Roman soldier
St. Martin of "Tours"--
patron saint of
package holidays.
In fact, St. Martin is
the patron saint of--
among other things-- the
US Army's Quartermaster d
And so popular was Martin for
many centuries after his death
that Martin Luther, the great
reformer, was named after him,
and baptized on his feast
day, November the 11th.
We marked it in the church
calendar on Monday this week.
And this whole
season of the year
is known in some
places as Martinmas.
You have Christmas.
You have Candlemas.
You have Michaelmas.
You also have Martinmas.
The University of St. Andrews
in Scotland, where I got my PhD,
calls this semester Martinmas
in their academic calendar.
There's an old proverb that
runs, "his Martinmas must come,
as it does to every hog."
In other words, all must
die, because November
was the great slaughtering
time of the Anglo-Saxons,
when fodder was all used up,
and oxen, sheep, and hogs
were killed and
salted for the winter.
So we've already found two
links between ourselves
here today in Christ
Chapel and Martin of Tours.
This building is called a chapel
because of his bisected capela,
and this time of year
is Martinmas because
of his November feast today.
Can we find a third
link with St. Martin?
Pleasingly, we can.
This third link is via that
building in Philadelphia
that I mentioned earlier,
for Christ Church in Philly--
on which this
building is modeled--
was itself modeled on a famous
church in central London
called St. Martin in the Fields.
As the name in the
fields would imply,
that church originally stood
out in the countryside.
But the city gradually
surrounded it,
and St. Martin in
the Fields is now
right in the heart of
the British capital,
next to Trafalgar Square
and the National Gallery.
It's one of the best-known
churches in England.
And the interior
of this building
owes an unmistakable
debt to that church--
the Corinthian columns,
the barrel ceiling,
the shape of the windows--
especially the tripartite
window behind me.
Christ Chapel Hillsdale is
the architectural grandchild
of St. Martin in the Fields.
So we have a threefold
link to Martin of Tours--
the etymological link,
the calendrical link,
the architectural link.
And a scripture reminds
us, a threefold cord
is not easily broken.
So let's think more
deeply about Martin
and his startling act
of generosity that
has never been forgotten.
How foolish of
him, we might say,
if we were in a skeptical
or a cynical mood.
How foolish of him
to start chopping up
his own clothes like that.
Wouldn't it have made
much better sense
to give the beggar money with
which he could have bought
himself a complete new cloak?
How impulsive and
how impractical.
How non-universalizable.
For after all, what about the
next beggar that he meets?
Will that beggar get
a quarter of the cloak
and the next beggar an eighth?
Where will it all end?
Jesus says in the gospels,
whoever has two cloaks,
let him share with
him who has none.
He said nothing about
slicing your cloaks in half.
Well, these sorts of questions
betray a rather pedantic
mindset, and they
overlook a crucial dream
that gives us the context
for the whole interaction.
In the dream,
Christ says, Martin
clothed me with his robe.
So the beggar turns out to be
a rather important character
in this memorable
incident unfolding
by the gates of Amiens--
or as Churchill would
say, "Am-eye-ens."
It would seem it's
not so much Martin,
but the shivering wretch by
the side of the road who's
the holy hero of the story.
Well, then, should we
imitate the beggar?
Should we dress
ourselves in rags,
give away all our
advantages, move to France?
England maybe, France never.
[LAUGHTER]
But again, these questions
betray a small-minded focus
on dragging some
policy proposal out
of this memorable encounter.
Martin and the beggar
met in the Roman Empire
of the fourth century,
where interaction is not
a template for social services
or the charitable sector
in a modern Western democracy.
Rather, I think,
it's a perennially
telling moral and spiritual
story about a sword and cloak.
Let's approach this story
poetically, symbolically.
Martin bore a sword.
He had power.
He had strength.
He wielded military might.
He enforced the Pax Romana.
No doubt he was a strong man
physically, who could actually
do harm with that weapon.
He had a sword.
But he also had a cloak.
Let us picture it as a warm,
soft, thick, richly-embroidered
garment, so very different
from the tattered rags
of the beggar.
The poor man's need was
on display for all to see,
but Martin, underneath
his garments,
was just another man like him.
What was the difference
between the two?
I'm put in mind of
Shakespeare's King Lear, who
tells us, "Through
tattered clothes,
great devices do appear.
Robes and furred
gowns hide all."
Clothing masks.
Clothing hides.
Without clothing, we're ashamed
and naked, like Adam and Eve
after the fall.
Everyone must have clothes.
They're a symbol of our
human frailty, of our need.
And perhaps more, especially
for those who pride themselves
on their power,
clothes are needed
to preserve that fragile
pretense of invulnerability.
For which of us
is never in need?
We here today don't lack
clothes on our backs, thank God.
But do we lack nothing?
How many of us are
privately struggling
with all sorts of
difficulties and deficiencies
this very morning?
Our relationships
are going awry.
Our health is giving
us pause for thought.
We're worried about our exams.
Where are we going
in life, and why?
But even if we're wholly
secure in our relationships,
even if we're utterly
confident about our abilities,
even if we've won first prize in
all the competitions we've ever
entered or ever
will enter, so what?
Our Martinmas must come,
as it does to every hog.
So this is where
we would do well,
I think, to consider the
sword and the cloak together,
where they meet.
Think of that sharp sword
and that stylish cloak.
And now, see the one
slicing the other in half.
See the frayed edge where
the sword went through.
But the sword went throughout
of generosity, nothing worse--
out of largeness of heart.
Martin's act may
have been impulsive,
but the impulse was one of
magnanimity, not one of hatred,
or despair, or violence.
His act was a recognition
that all human beings have
to shiver when they're cold.
So let us at least
stand by one another
compassionately, now giving,
now receiving, now feeling
our power, now
knowing our weakness.
It's curious when you think
about it really, isn't it,
that a chapel should be a place
for a torn cape, a fragment
of cloth.
How would it be, though, if
the cloak was still intact,
testimony only to Martin's
talent for self-preservation?
That would not have
been worked out
housing in a place of
honor, for there's nothing
very special about looking
out for number one.
But a cloak rent asunder, that's
another thing altogether--
bisected for all
the right reasons.
That's a cape of good hope.
It points us to other
severances, doesn't it?
More profound, eternal
severances even--
think of the curtain of
the temple torn in two.
Think of Christ's side
pierced with a spear.
Think of the rock in the desert
gushing forth water, when
Moses struck it with a rod.
The gash admits the grace.
It's the crack where
the light gets in,
as Leonard Cohen almost said.
And we all have swords and
cloaks of various kinds.
We have powers.
We have needs.
We have abilities.
We have deficiencies.
So this Martinmas, in this
marvelous, martial chapel,
I propose that we both
celebrate the sword
and acknowledge the cloak--
and above all, hallow the
intersection of the two,
where, in weakness,
strength is made perfect.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
REV. ADAM RICK: Please
stand for the benediction.
And now, by the grace
of almighty God,
may you be filled
with the knowledge
of his will and all
wisdom and understanding,
so as to walk in a manner
worthy of the Lord,
fully pleasing to
Him, and bearing
fruit in every good work.
And may you be
strengthened with all power
according to His glorious might,
for all endurance and patience
with joy, giving thanks
to Him in all things.
And the blessing of God
Almighty, the Father, the Son,
and the Holy Spirit be amongst
you and remain with you always.
Amen.
[ORGAN PLAYING]